You guys are going to hate me for it.
You know what I want.
I want one.
One example at eff.
Why we should believe the earth is flat.
You son of a bitch.
You want it so bad and I am high and drunk
too.
As long as it's a joke and it's funny,
I'm cold.
It gets angry.
It's not fun.
I'm not married to this route.
If it's job not married to it convinced me that it's flat.
There's no way I could do that.
God really?
There's not one example.
It takes about a year and a half and like wanting to have this to me very hard.
They not so strong.
You look at your sons cartoons.
It's all space.
I look at all my shit,
all the shit my son likes,
his everything is,
they're taking space.
Still doing research on this currently in space.
Direct everyone to Hashtag spaces fake doing research.
Is that real?
That's a real site.
Hashtag spaces fake.
It's something I'm investigating for my next hour
for legitimately looking deep into the folder.
There's mild dam.
Like what space?
No,
it's the same thing.
Okay.
Got It all wrong.
You've got it all wrong.
This is not very organized.
Know what I'm saying is that everybody couldn't have it all wrong,
but anybody that thinks the earth is flat,
they totally don't believe what we're taught about what's above us.
So fake.
What about the sun?
They mean all the stock information we're getting.
You're lying about that shit that,
it's not that it doesn't exist.
Of course it exists.
We see of course,
but space is fake.
Sounds ridiculous.
Like there's,
there's something.
I'm looking at it and it's it.
It's fake.
That's ridiculous.
That's not what it means.
It means that all the information we got to buy,
all their eyes in the sky,
something else,
their line to NASA law and there's a reason tell you,
but you guys who don't want to hear it,
hold on.
So I don't want to tell him to give us a,
like the cliff notes.
The cliff notes are man,
ah,
have you studied any kind of a,
he doesn't need to be.
Let's hear.
Just so few of if goal,
always been for the most powerful emperors is a one world government.
Always wanted a one world government.
All of the Roman emperors,
they tried to figure out,
they tried to do different combinations.
How about him?
And they would fall and they were a new emperor would come and go,
you know what?
I'm going to fucking rule domination.
I'm not going to let my soldiers get married that way.
We'll have a stronger army.
They have different philosophies.
Everyone believed different shit,
but they all wanted a one world government.
There is no way to have a fucking Walmart with government it.
Nobody's into that shit.
Not even other rules from small countries or like one world government that's
going to put me out of a job.
Fuck your one world government.
People don't know shit about politics.
Don't want a one world government.
There's no way you're going to sell the one world government.
It's impossible.
The only way,
the only way to make a one government work is to have the people embrace it.
They have to want it because nobody wants it.
So the trick is to make,
to make people want it,
to embrace it.
There's only one way I got to pay.
There's on the line morning,
Miss Allen's,
I noticed know the only way and the known this forever,
the Vatican knew this,
the Vatican,
the pope water to rule the world.
They all knew it but they couldn't do it.
They all knew it,
but they knew one way.
But there's no how they're going to put it away,
man.
The only way is if there was some extra terrestrial threat from up above us,
that would be the only way to have everyone embrace the one world government.
They all knew that for years they didn't work.
That's the plan.
They can never make Brando that they didn't have the technology 500 years ago.
The Vatican knew about it,
they wanted it.
And you go to the Vatican,
you see paintings,
that paintings of like have you let those with aliens in them and back when I
used to believe in Ufos,
but before I figured out that um,
Ufo is where are they want us to believe in Ufo as they're preparing us for a
fake alien invasion.
That's always been the plan.
A one world government.
The only way to do it is to get us to embrace it and the only way to embrace it
is from an alien attack.
Ronald Reagan talked about it many times at the UN CFR.
He talked about it because wouldn't it make,
he looked at all the leaders of the,
of the nature of the world and said,
what did it make our lives easier if we just had some,
you know,
some kind of extra terrestrial threat.
He said,
that shit,
he said that in front of the UN wouldn't.
Aw,
he's trying to get everybody into Dan too.
I don't think he ever said no,
no.
He said that many times.
A 10 video montage.
Ronald Reagan,
Ronald Reagan
was vice president.
He was talking about,
and there's many videos of him saying,
we are what lies before us.
He's in front of the nation doing it.
State of the Union address,
saying what lies before us.
Is the opportunity to forge a new world,
order a world,
an order because he's talking about like,
isn't that means that the spaces for yes.
No,
no,
no.
When people ask me,
why would they fake space?
It's always been about a fake alien attack.
You can't have a fake alias politics.
Never fake an attack without space.
But I've never heard of politics.
You have to have space first.
So they always,
you know,
who promoted space more than anybody who want Nazis.
Nazis,
not before the Nazis.
You know,
mine's the Vatican.
They have all the biggest,
uh,
they have all the astronomers.
They're all Jesuit Vatican's,
all of them.
All the ones that are giving us this information about space.
They all come from the Vatican.
The Vatican has the most beautiful towns come here.
Know what the name of the [inaudible] doesn't have the most powerful,
you know what his name is?
The most powerful telescope.
The Bat again,
and you know what name it is.
I've done the research on Youtube.
Hi Nancy folks.
But you're done with this.
Do you know what the mass one and chill is the most Pelo power telescope in the
world?
It's in the Vatican.
But do you know the,
what's Lucifer falls?
Lucifer's Dick and balls.
Never seen this fucking town.
Really legit,
dude.
Uh,
I think the biggest ones in Chile,
I think they have to be in high altitude paddock.
Yeah.
I don't think it's in the Vatican.
When people ask me why would they fake all this shit,
but I don't think they got to go bed.
It's just a crazy theory.
I'm trying to,
I'm just,
it certainly has.
We're talking to these Ellis,
these funny theory,
but Eddie,
these new chilay,
very large array telescopes that they're creating are fucking gigantic and they
take over enormous pieces of land.
Google does very large array.
It's called not,
it's called the very large telescope telescope.
I watched the documentary with you at your house.
It was like 2001 and I think five years.
They're going up.
They're putting the documentary about them putting together the very large
telescope in Chile and they're talking about by the year 2005 we're going to
have this,
we're going to have three telescopes are linked with a computer to make us,
we're going to see further into space than ever before.
None of that shit came.
What are you talking about?
Camp is that there's a very,
very large array up yet no large telescope.
But I know they have,
they have them in Hawaii.
Weird,
isn't it weird that every space documentary all the series,
I had them all,
Jo,
Adam,
all we watch them all the time.
I tried to remember all the shit about a neutron star and a super hyper Nova.
I was ball state were balls deep into space and then every now and then we'd
watch this documentary after documentary.
Morgan Freeman ain't got the universe.
We had a shit.
Shit,
I DVR and all that shit.
Anything that's at space still smells fucking ball.
I thought it was better than people and shit cause I knew so much about space
and every now and then I'd watch all that shit and wonder and wonder why this is
all cartoons,
Eddie Watt.
But it's just so hard.
And then I go,
okay,
whatever,
whatever.
And then I keep watching all DVDs on space or I'll CGI,
there's nothing real and everyone watches that.
They believe it.
The narration is all programming what's above us and what we're on.
We're being lied to.
Once you go flat,
you never go back.
Listen,
if you think campaign,
they listen.
They're lying to us about everything.
This is the one thing I want to say.
Okay?
It's not that we believe something ridiculous and you don't.
You don't believe it.
We're gullible.
We,
we believe some weird shit about the flat earth.
We believe some weird shit.
You don't believe it.
You're smart.
It's not about that.
It's about we actually don't know what we're on.
And we always say that we don't know,
but based on all the shit that we got by the mainstream,
we don't believe that.
Here's what you believe that I see.
It's not that we believe something crazy and you don't because you smell it.
The bullshit.
Isn't there a sense that
we are get a totally different tool we looked at as you use
and we don't really any of them.
Yeah,
but you use,
we don't.
And if you use that microphone,
use a cell phone.
Right?
It's science.
Hold on.
I believe that.
I believe in it.
Okay.
Why do you believe in that and want to believe but study.
I don't need to read something to verify,
but when you benefit,
benefit,
you benefit for every day.
I know.
I love this and why we'll need to cut this.
It's 10 o'clock.
Come see me in Vancouver at the vogue theater and in Salt Lake City at wise
wiseguys March one and two I love science too.
I love science.
I don't want to fight.
I want to laugh about it.
I'm an idiot.
I believe in flatter.
I'm crazy.
That's all you need to know.